هذا هو معسكر كريو للاجئين القادمين من
جنوب السودان يقعوا المعسكر في ولايه شرق
دارفور محليه بحر العرب الحدوديه مع ولايه
بحر الغزال بجنوب السودان تضم معسكرات
اللاجئين المتواجدين في شرق دارفور اكثر
من 200 الف لاجئ موزعين في محليات مختلفه
بولايه شرق دارفور خروج المنظمات المفاجئ
اثره كثيرا على واقع المعسكرات هنا بشرق
دارفور خاصه فيما يتعلق بخدمات المياه
هنالك منظمات كانت تقوم بتشغيل محطات
كثيره
بمعسكرات اللجوء بشرق دارفور كانت تجلب
الوقود وايضا تقوم بعمليات صيانه هذه
المحطات هذه الاعمال توقفت في الايام التي
شهدت قتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بمغادره منظمات تعمل في هذا الحقل لابد
انه نحتاج الى مساعده المنظمات خاصه في
توفير الوقود لتشغيل مضخات المياه من هذا
المعسكر نرسل النداء الى المنظمه
الانسانيه التي كانت تعمل معنا لتوفير
الوقود لان الماء هو شريان الحياه
بالاضافه لمعاناه المياه هنالك ايضا شح
واضح في الخدمات الصحيه هنالك منظمات كانت
تقوم بتشغيل مستشفيات داخل معسكرات اللجوء
اليوم توقفت هذه المستشفيات خاصه بعد دمار
عدد كبير من مخازن الدواء باقليم دارفور
في جنوب دارفورد
نحن على ابواب فصل الخريف حيث يتوالد
البعوض والذباب وتنتشر الامراض تبعا لذلك
لا تتوفر حاليا ادويه في المعسكر وزاره
الصحه بولايه شرق دارفور كانت ترسل لنا
الادويه عبر الجنينه والفاشر وانيال ولكن
بسبب الاوضاع الحاليه فلن تستطيع ارسال
الادويه
اللاجئين في دار الدينجا وصل عدد سكان
المعسكر في شرق دارفور الى اكثر من 250
الف شخص وهذا عدد كبير نناشد الحكومه
بارسال نداء الى المنظمات لاننا نحتاج الى
الماء والدواء والغذاء وبحسب مسؤولين داخل
المعسكر ما زالت عمليات الوصول الى معسكر
كريم ومستمره من ولايه الخرطوم ومن ولايه
اخرى في اقليم دارفور الولايات التي شهدت
اضطرابات ومعارك خلال الايام الماضيه
الامر الذي يحتاج الى تدخل عاجل من
المنظمات لانغاز الموقف
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات